[Musique]
donc c'est à ce genre is it en fait tu
vas bosser sur le plateau régis est
malade c'est moi ton assistant trail
aujourd'hui après t'inquiète pas il va
revenir un tu me verras plus mais moi
bora tout cas ça me fait plaisir mais
autre loi ok ce moment est gênant tu es
prêt oui oui je termine juste ça
j'arrive aussi à des tâches dont vous
êtes le nom sur le média parce que
[Musique]
ton équipe et je peux même pas équipés
de bada mon temps je vais parler de
choix pour écouter ça va être très
simple tout le monde me connaît ici je
suis tout sauf méchant et je veux but et
personne alors à faire comme tous les
jours vous vous allez lancer le jt comme
si de rien n'était et moi je vais passer
un message en direct tout simplement
ce serait quand même dommage que
quelqu'un prenne une balle bêtement nom
et là ça serait dommage
toi tu fais ce que je te dis je fais ce
que tu veux rien faire christie je fais
quoi là
et c'est quoi j'me bouge le cul
justement c'est pas ton concept préféré
ça mais c'est quoi ce délire là lance
l'émission toi mais c'est qui ce ghana
c'est notre ingé son madame c'est
n'importe quoi
qu'est ce qu'il veut et encore je veux
juste passer un message annonce marine
là c'est quoi votre message sur notre
gouvernement notre monde ne prend pas
des mesures drastiques notre
civilisation court à sa perte
vous êtes tous complices de ça là vous
me dégoûtez ah ouais donc on est sur un
message écolo c'est bien beau rivage le
match mais juste que je te dis je fais
ce que tu dis bon déjà si on veut
trouver une solution je propose qu'on
arrête de le prendre de haut le mec ne
braquent
je suis d'accord avec toi mais tu penses
pas que le monde serait mieux sans nous
pourquoi la terre l aqua quatre
milliards et demi d'années et nous en à
peine un siècle d'industrialisation
on est unique et c'est bien ça mais
qu'est ce que tu veux faire on est tous
victimes là dedans sur la planète elle
se sentira très bien sans nous pour
arrêter d'être les enfants moi j'ai
arrêté j'ai jeté ma cape
on n'est pas des super héros moi j'en
peux plus de me sentir démuni face à
tout ça je me dégoûte
et quitte à avoir envie de mourir tous
les jours autant que ce soit pour le
bien commun et oued venir c'est là où
j'en suis dans ma vie maintenant
basi le dit le fait pitié c'est ça ma
réalité va-t-on catherine en gros on
embauche que des fouilles à l'émission
maintenant ok olivier fait pas le congo
fait puisque 100 mg r je vais juste tiré
dans la jambe c'est rien lancé
l'émission chez vous s'il vous plaît en
régie s'il vous plaît aux cas on va
envoyer maintenant c'est parti
3-2 à gauche bonjour le monde
et oui vous êtes en train d'assister à
un message pas comme les autres
aujourd'hui monsieur personnes à la
parole en exclusivité pour une fois vous
allez pouvoir avoir une version des news
sans réécriture et sans transformation
nous sommes pareils au fond je le sais
nous vivons sans savoir quoi faire ni
comment et moi aujourd'hui je désespère
je désespère de voir nos dirigeants
participé à l'effondrement de notre
civilisation
et tout ça pour quelques privilèges on
vous parle de réchauffement climatique
on vous parle d' épuisement de
ressources de de la crise économique et
tout ça c'est votre faute
notre faute pourquoi à
parce qu'on prend des douches trop
longue parce qu'on met du papier dans la
poubelle verte et pages jaunes et
pendant qu'on est là à discuter bien
sagement d'écologie pour se donner bonne
conscience il ya deux mille tonnes de
nitrate d'ammonium compéter à l'autre
bout du monde faisant des centaines de
morts et des dizaines de blessés et s'il
nous étions les prochaines victimes
victimes de notre propre sort
aujourd'hui je suis écoeuré je suis
écoeuré de ne pouvoir voir un monde dans
lequel on prendra soin de son prochain
où le mot exploitation n'existe plus
alors réveillez vous la réveillez vous
parce que derrière nos t-shirts à 40
euros se cachent des esclaves modernes
c'est triste un mémoire dans le fond je
laime ce monde avec vous on pourra tout
changer et ensemble
nous ferons honneur à ce que nous sommes
et à l'humanité
[Musique]
allez
envolées gare
respecte
c'est bon on a pu éviter le pire c'est
le message est passé
oui tous les médias ont débloqué coiffer
et le live
non c'est comme si rien n'avait jamais
existé au bras vous vous avez été très
courageuse
allez
pas formalisé
[Musique]
à